bonjour à tous quand on doit retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro c dans le sud de
l'île que je vous emmène plus exactement
à manapany néo où on va aller partager
le quotidien de didier sort s y
installer sa ferme-auberge ici je pense
qu on a fait trop loin mais bien
à tort
hama
il est temps dans l'est sur la bonne
voie
thomas
et lyon
pas de doute ça on est bien au bon
endroit ferme auberge dit là et on va
voir si notre hôte est présent oui
arrive oui à lui guillaume bon tu vois
ça va et toi alors il ya à prendre un
peu d'air dans les eaux ouais je suis
venu puis un petit coup de moins bien
génial mais en plus il tombe bien nous
les leur plein dans la basse à cuisine
c'est bon à savoir
ça va je me souviens aller à lons
c'est pour être si oui et j'ai encore
jamais goûté sa basse et bon ben voilà
l'occasion les lie à part ça du coup guy
lacombe à deux coups même capacité ton
ta ferme auberge un gîte de groupe de
neuf personnes
ouais et là un petit chalet pour couples
principalement avec capacité deux
adultes deux enfants
donc c'est possible de venir apprécier
un petit week-end avec sa chérie par la
revoilà avait tout à fait c'est fait
pour
c'est fait pour bon alors ils sont
cachés ou tma 20 cibles nova coupe ça
l'a déjà fait et en plus il tombe bien
on a un régime banane pour couper sinon
les trois on va manger tout bon
évidemment un coup de main alors là oui
je suis là pour sa chef
allez lequel nous travaillons
bas-madawaska il faut pas non non là il
faut récupérer gindt ensuite on mate et
pourquoi crassous c'est bon zazie
attends je les biens moment pas de doute
c'est bon à l'épaule doucement
maintenant je m'occupe de tout ça demain
si bon ok super ça c'est fait voilà où
un oral des siens possible le midi on
peut pour manger la wii elle est tombée
cariou finale général bon bah écoute pas
ça un instant allons récupérer ma part
maintenant
il en faut bien un peu près pour ne pas
le cas et l'actu faire là se trouvent
trois ou quatre très bien la carte tient
la partie
à
à l'aller propres et non en fait comment
tu sais ces prêts aussi pas prêt par
exemple vous voit les bahamas et contre
les bananes et les banaboo de bois
nature ya donc là reconnaît que les
frappes manager donc là et nationale il
est super league entre les moines
bon alors notre boîte à face on
préparait le bal masqué où passent à la
râpe au moins on reconnaît que quand
voir il trop faux sperian dedans alors
oui bah war est comme ça au moins on n'a
pas cette amertume c'est l'action dana
qui donne le goût un petit peu de
l'agréable et du coup en faisant comme
ça où on récupère traitement au voir
m'ont donné un petit peu de rouge donc
ça allait pas derrière lui pas grave ça
c'est police et plus la petite banane le
fruit même que comme c'est un petit
fruit n'est pas encore mature c'est plus
ça qui va donner un petit goût
désagréable en fait dénoncé dans comme
ça ça va
voilà on ne commence à arriver au petit
petite banane l'intérieur et donc du
coup tu crois que tu proposes quoi la
carte là parce que là on entre les
cuisiner à roubaix six ballons mais
c'est pas comme toujours pareil c'est
pas le principe de restaurant le
restaurant où arrive on va demander
trace à ça et là c'est pas du tout le
cas là sera plus le repas en fonction de
ce que la table il peut proposer
donc on a un banal roguet saucisses bas
m'a fait aller ça des produits voilà des
produits longtemps des petits repas
traditionnel pas en général d'ailleurs
pas traditionnel on peut rester c'est du
tout simple poulets canards fort que
lapin l'éthique comme ça et après il
fait aussi bien les repas de famille
tout ce que les repas non pas de fête au
cerro imagine fed les communions les
baptêmes anniversaires les petits
mariage les repas de comité d'entreprise
voilà le travail avec des produits les
producteurs locaux
que ce soit au niveau des hauts niveaux
des légumes au niveau des viandes et
tout ça s'est passé des trucs comme à la
fois à dispo sur petit sénat de tout on
trouve de tout c'est quoi ces des
produits bio pas forcément bio mais
raisonné d'avoir un coup là situé devant
la différence entre mais ce site lambda
et des vrais saucisses
ça c'est de la vraie sur six même au
bout et arrive à reconnaître sa voix il
chante mieux elles sont mûres vraiment
sont plus forts
barry cultuel et encontre est ancrée
comédie la petite île ville à la
campagne on a l'a fait de l'arrêt il a
fait des agrumes la fête la fête du
tango pourquoi est-ce que tu as choisi
la commune de petite île pourtant comme
une bêtise c'est par ce moyen petit
loire mois et nés et grandis petit il
n'en petite-ilois de naissance et se
taira là c'était un terrain qui
appartenait à mon grand père
c'est quoi les flores d'ailleurs dédiée
ce et des fleurs
voilà après une matinée passée dans la
cuisine à préparer ce magnifique
ou est ce si ce n'est pas fini on va
maintenant passer à table et il sait me
repasser sacré donc en ce qui concerne
la caméra
oui
et ça y est on a bien mangé oui merci
pour ce repas d'ailleurs ben écoute avec
plaisir je garderai s'entête la rouille
saucisses baba fixes et frais chez moi
et du coup pour la direction a décidé de
m'emmener faire une petite balade
oui est ce que tu peux me dire où est ce
qu'on est alors là au piton de
grand-anse temps grange du côté du côté
bas du côté saint pierre ducout donc là
avec la vue justement sur le bassin de
gros temps cela mon pain béni en toute
sécurité et dans les eaux là je
commençais l'hôtel et ont longtemps tout
droit là c'est la pauvre bête il ya une
partie pâtissier une patte saint-pierre
montvert donc on a une belle gueule donc
une belle vue un endroit calme avec une
vue assez lâches et l'océan
effectivement on est juste à côté de
chez soi bah oui on a peine 15 minutes
ouais bon sur la plage
je
j'aurais bien profiter de ces petits
moments de calme mais en fin de journée
pour parler un peu plus de toit en un
petit peu plus de ce qui t'a amené à ce
métier de ferme aubergiste de ton
parcours
juste avant c'était ce night restaurant
et moi très bien travaillé aussi bien
dans le dans le domaine administratif
dont on a été dans les bureaux on a été
sur le terrain et à un moment c'est un
retour aux sources aux normes et à l'été
n'avait une grande ferme une grande
basse quoi dans le dans la bande à
kouadio du coc et donc toute mon enfance
arrivé là bas ma place était dans la
basse-cour d'entre eux au milieu des
canards des poules et des pigeons et
lapins
c'est de retour aux sources mais
ressources peut-être pourquoi peut-être
pour retrouver ce côté calme apaisant de
la nature
que retrouve certainement pas dans un
bureau on retrouve certainement pas dans
un travail avec des collègues avec donc
nous n'a pas ça là dedans et on a pu
voir aussi que certains de tes bob tu
faisais la main oui j'adore ces meubles
et structures meubles structure est
effectivement au tchad et au sénat
le faible comme ça autonome c'est
quelque chose d'important pour fallait y
penser plus à une façon de de
matérialiser des souhaits des envies des
rêves c'est des trucs que l'était
peut-être là en dormance à l'intérieur
et que l'était le matérialiser à un
moment et heureusement d'ailleurs que
moi la ceca passé de faire donc d'une
certaine manière finalement toute cette
ferme auberge dinars l'extériorisation
de tes rêves
oui exactement s'il affirme dina
comme vous pouvez le voir à mater pour
vient de se lever
c'est une matinée qui débute ici à la
ferme auberge dina qui dit ferme auberge
10 fermes qui dit ferme des animaux est
ici chaque matin commence par
l'entretien des animaux et je vais aller
rejoindre didier qui doit déjà être en
train de s'affairer c'est quand même
super agréable de se révéler au grand
jour
or a bien dormi
ça va ça va ah bah si j'avais su
j'aurais attendu pour prendre la douche
a donc du coup c'est ça que tu leur
donne à manger à des cochons ça ouais en
bas c'est vrai qu'un petit aperçu de ce
qu'on va partout mais hier soir en fait
donc tu as des cochons oui t'as canard
oui j'ai entendu des cadres et criant tu
peux pas la balle à cabris moutons
quelques moutons
lakhouad aux poulains choisi way lapin
lapin dadon niada
je pas sûr qu'elle apprécie n'est
gratuit dans l'oreille ou alors et qui
sait pas ou alors elle adore
ils sont adorables
du coup ça peut donc aussi de cette
ferme beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
choses signale la basse-cour de la grand
mère la tante et l'animateur faisait ça
tous les matins
non la banane les plus sûrs que des
profits là bas c'est quand y arriver
tout est fini c'est juste un ciel voilé
canal alpha il apprécie s'occuper des
animaux
millions
juste faire gaffe aux faisans c'est quoi
son nom anna pape nom n'a pas de nom à
paris faisant me donne pas de nom en
général les animaux et j'imagine que son
statut de mascotte le préserve de toute
heure ah oui et c est ce que de marc
mais de tout risque de cuisson sur
l'écriture c'est pas la chance que tu as
la petite chance secret du coup les
pigeons c'est pareil c'est juste pour
l'atteindre pédagogique services
travaillent quels types de publics du
coup pour la ferme alors le public c bat
déjà tous publics
après les écoles et puis battus et les
personnes handicapées les enfants ou
adultes handicapées ou âgées
donc c'est plus une forme découverte
ferme de découverte comme des grands
clubs ça du coup c'est important pour
toi quand tu as ouvert congi jean
d'amour à l'espace là à côté là où
partager se faisait désirer cette
nostalgie
bon ben on va devoir y aller tant merci
pour tout marc plaisir tous engagés
n'ont pas vraiment le temps de dire au
revoir à tous les pensionnaires dont tu
fais pas pour moi
et puis à très très vite hier au 4 mai
pour ça au plaisir bail von roll et bien
c'est là dessus que va se tenir cet
épisode alors je sais pas pour vous mais
moi j'ai vraiment passé un excellent
moment en compagnie de didier qui au
passage nous rappeler qu'avec une petite
dose de fois une grande dose pour le
coup l'huile de coude il est possible
d'aller au bout de chacun de nos rêves
ceci mis à part si vous avez envie de
passer un petit week end en amoureux si
vous avez envie de découvrir la culture
culinaire local ou simplement la vie à
la ferme
je venais adresse ça se passe à la ferme
auberge dit la compagne de didier se
laisse ici sur la commune de petite île
en ce qui nous concerne on se retrouve
très vite sur les routes de la réunion a
plus